I cannot tell you how sick of and
disgusted by this new incoming
Republican Congressman George Santos I
am
um this is the guy who earlier in the
week I told you that the openly gay
Jewish Republican who had been elected
lied about his employment history
and he lied about his educational
history
and he lied that four of his employees
were victims in the Pulse Nightclub
shooting
and that it was lie after lie after lie
and then after that we learned okay well
he lied about all of those things but he
is Jewish right it appears that he lied
about being Jewish as well
okay I said
at least he really is gay
and I said it jokingly because of course
he is
and it has now been revealed that three
years ago he was married to a woman now
you could be gay
and have been married to a woman we know
of situations that do too stigma or
family shame or for whatever reason that
a member of the LGBT community might
live in a way that is different than
their true feelings and maybe that's the
case with this guy but he hid the fact
that he had been married to a woman and
divorced her as recently as just a
couple years ago and he lied about
everything else so what are we to
believe and it is just stunning openly
gay congressman-elect George Santos
didn't disclose divorce with woman
writes Roger sullenberger for The Daily
Beast Santos ran his campaign as an
openly gay Republican since he was
elected a number of key biographical
details have started to crumble here is
the latest one
and it is yet another one of these cases
where we find out that the truth appears
to be very different from the story that
he told as the article reads and in the
this is accurate Santos who claims he
has quote never experienced
discrimination in the Republican Party
broke barriers when he became the first
openly gay non-incumbent Republican
candidate elected to congress but
according to court records obtained by
The Daily Beast Santos appeared to be
the subject of a previously
unacknowledged September 2019 divorce
almost September almost 2020 rather with
a woman in Queens County New York the
divorce which Santos has not discussed
publicly adds new uncertainty to his
already shaky biographical and political
claims I am openly gay have never had an
issue with my sexual identity in the
past decade and I can tell you and
assure you I will always be an advocate
for lgbtq folks now maybe he's bisexual
he didn't say that
um maybe there's some other explanation
but when you've lied about everything it
starts to become very very difficult to
believe that we also have additional new
information about the stories related to
his supposed Jewish ancestry CNN
reporting incoming congressman's claim
his grandparents fled the Holocaust
contradicted by genealogy records and as
I said earlier this week it's not Stolen
Valor we apply that to the military but
it is taking it is appropriating a story
that includes trauma and oppression and
discrimination that your family did not
suffer and making it your own and it's
disgusting
um stack and Kaczynski right for CNN
claims by George Santos that his
grandparents quote survived the
Holocaust as Ukrainian Jewish refugees
from Belgium who changed their surname
to survive are contradicted by sources
reviewed by CNN's k-file including
family trees compiled by genealogy
websites records on Jewish refugees and
interviews with multiple genealogists
Santos who has called himself half
Jewish and a Latino Jew folks I'm
actually a Latino Jew okay
has claimed his maternal grandfather was
originally from Ukraine
and fled to Brazil to escape Nazism
sounds like my family history to
Argentina except fake in another telling
the New York Republican said his
grandparents converted to Catholicism
during the rise of Nazism in Belgium
after fleeing Stalin in another telling
he claimed his family changed their name
to survive Nazism anyway no proof of
those claims it all appears to be
completely and totally made up
so
there's a lot of important things here
I don't want to Discount the possibility
that for whatever reason
it happens that gay people marry they
get in a heterosexual marriage and
there's all sorts of different reasons
and if that's what happened but he lied
about everything else well then we can
still talk about all those other things
but
this guy it's hard to find a more
dishonest person than George Santos
based on what we've seen and learned so
far and so I believe everything has to
be under the microscope now does it
matter he was voted by the people to
become a congressman and he is
congressman-elect as I said earlier this
week in any normal job not a job where
you're elected
you would be fired for misstating so
much about your history now you wouldn't
declare your sexual orientation as part
of a normal job interview so that's kind
of off the table
I don't know that if you tell your
employer you're Jewish and you're not I
don't know about that having
consequences but your resume where you
worked where you got your your degree
these are things where if it turned out
you falsified it you would be fired
essentially in just about every job and
so what happens next what happens next
with this guy probably nothing quite
frankly but a disgusting turn of events
and what started with he may have
um misstated or exaggerated his work
history and his role as what was it like
an asset manager or something
it seems his entire background is
completely and totally fake I'm gonna
now take another step back it does seem
this guy is from the species Homo
sapiens that appears to be true he
claims to be human he presents as human
I believe he is actually human maybe
that's the next thing that will be
proven wrong
I love reading I read every day no
matter how I arrange my schedule I never
have enough time to read all the books
that I want which is why blinkist has
been such an important part of my life
for years now our sponsor blinkist is
the app that takes thousands of
non-fiction books boils them down into
an explainer that you can read or listen
to in just 15 minutes which includes all
the most important takeaways from the
book with blinkist I can absorb the
essence of 15 different books in an
afternoon so I can quickly gather
insights from all sorts of perspectives
make connections have those kind of aha
moments that don't happen so easily
which is why I feel enriched when I use
blinkist blinkist also summarizes
episodes of popular podcasts into
15-minute explainers and with the
blinkist connect feature my girlfriend
and I can share one account share books
podcasts with each other talk about them
on the go and don't for forget blinkus
makes the perfect holiday gift my
audience can try blinkist free for seven
days and get 25 percent off after that
go to blinkist.com Pacman the link is
down below